hello everyone and welcome to the
penultimate round of the fractious
festival it's round eight and it's a
visit who is leading the tournament
against David navara who is playing on
with home-field advantage but so far he
didn't really get get his break in the
tournament and if it can win this game
is going to be well it's really gonna do
wonders for his standing says he's
already a leading determined by a point
and a half ahead of everyone and I
really want to show this game yesterday
it's it's a really amazing game but I
have to go to Zagreb I couldn't do it so
that's why I'm only showing it now but
you will enjoy it so without further ado
let's check it out but it opens a width
D for now we Knight to f6 c4 e6 Knight
to f3 and b6
Navarro goes for the Queen's Indian
defense which is which is some of the
bolt as alpha0 pretty much I will pretty
much refuted the whole idea with a three
bishop to b7 and Bishop to f4 now with
d5 striking in the center C captures
Knight captures now you could capture
with the pawn but then you block your
own light square bishop diagonal so
Knight captures attacking the bishop and
the bishop back to g3 and here Knight to
d7 now maybe this night is coming at f6
but also you are supporting this c5
thrust and here there is a game where
Queen to c2 was played in there is one
game work and I studied Knight bTW - was
played but here we have E 4 and it is
already as of mo8 that we have a
completely new game so what's what's
happening here the knife goes back to f6
and now II five once again asking do you
want to maybe go to d5 to e4 but Navarro
goes after the bishop knife to h5 who
wants to get rid of the dark square
bishop we have Knight to c3 and Bishop
to e7 continuing development preparing
to castle and with it continues with
Bishop to c4 with the knight awkwardly
placed on d7 visit now gains control of
the d5 square and he has some idea of
maybe executing d5 and here castling is
definitely an idea but Navarro goes for
a6 he says okay or d5 idea
have any marriage to it you are welcome
to push it if you want so vidit pushes
with d5 and now again if 95 you guard e6
square it's not a problem if captures
you can trade the Queen so white it does
look a bit weird for black but black
should be able to come out okay
however Navarro goes for each capture
son b5 we've got shop CalPERS on d5 now
the problem is if captures captures you
you do have some problems here for
example you still can't castle if you
Castle then e 6 comes with a double
attack here so you're only your only
option is Knight f6 for the Knights to
be guarding each other but now captures
on f7 and black could be could be
somewhat weakened here Quinn goes back
now already Knights to g5 is an idea and
it's it it's a tough position to play so
instead after Bishop captures on d5 we
have Knight captures and g3 first by
navara H captures and g3 and now c6
saying that you should really move your
bishop or you could try something that
III don't think that actually works and
here we read you the position from the
thumbnail without further ado video goes
for it Bishop captures an f7 and I mean
who wouldn't idiot er goes or it doesn't
but if this goes you're basically
winning the tournament so King captures
on f7 and now how do you continue the
attack of course II 6 with check saying
I either win my piece back or you have
to bring your King deeper into the
center of the board
so King captures on a on e6 is the only
move that really gives gives the
advantage to black not advantage but it
is the only way to kind of justify that
c6 more and allowing the sacrifice and
here is the moment where we really need
to decide what to do here well we could
we could even award a visit the Morphy
had a head for this so let's just do
that with it here we go here's a morphe
head feel free to pause the video what
would you play here and how will you
continue this this attack well I'll give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who are able to do it
congratulations on being a spectacular
attacker if you found the following idea
now and for those we
you just want to enjoy the show Venice
played queen that eat you check it's a
good move but there is a better one for
example Queen to b3 chair - not so much
because King d6 and then the king runs
away you don't really have anything
going on here
however Quinta a4 is incredibly strong
but it's it's such a disgusting engine
line that I will only show because it's
well it deserves to be it to be showed
so after this you cannot go something
like king these six to try and run away
because of the simple queen of for
checking goes back and night the d4 is
made so that idea doesn't work
so after kinked a queen to a4 you'd have
to go Knight to c5 attack the Queen
Queen to c4 check King to f6 and now the
mood that's incredibly hard to find
especially when you're when your queen
is still on d1 when you're pondering on
Quinte for rook to h4 and this is just
finding all these moves is pretty much
impossible now the problem is the rook
is coming to f4 if rook for Czech Queen
f7 is game over so let's say 93 check
the knight is guarded by the Queen also
the f4 square is now guarded King to f1
getting out of check now c5 opening up
this bishops diagonal and the now rook
to d1 threatening to win to win back the
piece so b5 you attack the Queen now
Knight e4 check if you move the king
then Quinta east sex will be deadly so
you have to capture it and after Queen
card for c4 you manage to keep your
knight
but now finally why rooked age 4 was so
so strong rook the f4 with check and the
King has no moves so what do you do you
have to capture it and now of course you
lose the Queen but not just yet Queen
captures an f4 King e6 now you deliver a
check Knight d4 check King goes back
King D 7 now Knights the f5 check again
came back to see it now you will capture
rock actress Bishop captures and now
Knight to d6 check and here you do have
two rooks and the bishop against the
Queen and night but it is a it is a
winning attack for white for example
King D 7 are you gonna go tonight the f7
and you lose the rook and once you lose
the rock is game over because if you try
and save the rook then its Knight to e5
with check King moves
to guard the rook of course Quinta efore
now with an attack against the rook and
also threatening a lot of nasty
discoveries so after the rook moves now
Knight g6 check finally you go after the
rook and if king f7 to defend it now
just captures and if captures Queen to
f5 check picks up the rook so that's
only one of the lines but really after
the skin captures honey honey sex really
incredible stuff that happens on the
board after Queen teh for of course it's
impossible to calculate everything this
was only one line and there are endless
possibilities that that are possible
after Queen teh for a bogey if it goes
for Quinta e to with check we have King
to f7 and now he goes for Queen side
castles product now it's very important
to have the rookin and the same file as
the Queen and also you might have ideas
of of a nice rook lift now not with rook
page for obviously but maybe you're
gonna go rook to e1 or maybe rope the h5
maybe 10 5 who knows Bishop to f6 and
now now comes Knight to e4 again going
for Knight to d6 check the Bishop on b7
is undefended and Queen to e7 now and
here again with it has to decide how to
go about this position now again he goes
for Knight to d6 check to win back the
material right away
Queen to c4 check or Queen to c2 check
getting the Queen away from the e-file
because that square belongs to the rogue
that's why Quinta a4 was also incredibly
powerful in a lot of lines because you
get the d1 square in the e5 e 1 square
for your rooks but okay let's see Queen
to see for chuggy you cannot block with
the Queen because of Knight checks then
you just exchange the para Knights and
then the other night checks and forms
the Queen so you'd have to move and then
rook to H 2 e 1 and you get this again
incredibly complicated position where
okay you've sacrificed the piece for the
attack but this rook is not coming into
play anytime soon this is this is really
anyone's game
however really decided to go for 4
material equality he played 96 check we
have King to f8 now he traded Queens
captures captures and Knight captures on
b7 so now he rubbed the piece back and
he's up upon but
sorry and not up upon the the material
is equal and also his bones are are kind
of doubled here we have night back to f6
and now Knight to e5 so okay he's still
very much ahead in development and this
is still a much better position for
white now the c6 pawn is under attack
but Knight to d5 saying that okay if you
capture the pawn now I have looked the
c8 and I'm gonna win win back some
material for example rookie actress and
e5 rook captures here with check King
moves and now now you will be up upon
but still I'm very very confident that I
can play this and it's hard to imagine
how this night will come out of the well
his cage because these two squares are
guarded twice you're gonna play King f7
bring the rook over to be a not
something you want to do so instead
after this move King to be one not
interested in occupying the same square
first after Luke to see it comes so now
look the c8 the pawn is nicely defended
and now rook H that you want if you're
thinking about Knight to g6 it looks
very interesting but it's not because
after Knight checks you're gonna move
the King Knight characters and a true
characters on h8 and your knight and b7
is lost whatever you play next move it's
rugby at rook captures and b7 and your
ear black will just have two pieces for
a rook which will of course be much
better for black so after Luke to c8 we
have Luke H to e1 centralizing the rooks
and now again an interesting tactic by
navara really going for the for the
stubborn defense refusing to give vidit
at this point bishop characters on a3
incredible stuff a point is after
captures you have nice the c3 check and
now you're gonna pick up the rook came
here knife characters rook captures
sorry King capture son d1 and now look
the c7 going after the night but after
Knight to d8 it will be it will be very
safe for white you will not be able to
win back either leader of the Knights so
white will again be much better here
threatening to pick up the c6 pawn it's
attacked twice and also you're
threatening Knights the e6 check which
would win the rook definitely a
difficult position but visitor doesn't
go for
instead of capturing the bishop he goes
for night captures on c6 and okay he now
he wants characters captors but now
Navarro goes back Bishop to b4 attacking
the rook here Knight captures Knight
captures and now rook to d7 a very nice
rock lifts and the other rock lifts it
will will will soon follow with h5
trying to get this rock into the game
this way and now Knight to d6 attacking
the rook we look back to a eight and now
rook 87 and now looking at this position
you might be thinking it's finally over
read it with it is finally winning this
but as you all know anything can happen
in chess so look to h7 defending the
pawn and mountain Knight to e4 sorry
that's not a for Knights the e4 again
with some very sneaky ideas for example
if if navara tried to tell it's a trade
one of the rooks rook e8 then it's a
very simple captures captures and the
knight f6 check checks the King defends
the rook and also well if you do nothing
just Knight captures rook so we'd have
to capture it and then we'll capture sin
h7 our winning endgame for white so
after Knight to e4 rook to h6 again
navara finds a very very active ideas we
have rook after sin g7 he gives up this
point for rook to d8 rook to d8
sorry for rook to b8 now asking do you
want to capture this rook and then I'm
gonna capture this rook and here with it
really needs to decide what to do here
with it played b3 the problem is if you
move the rook somewhere let's say here
for some reason then rook the d1 is mate
you of course cannot allow this
you should go however for something like
check and then after King moves deliver
another check King moves and then b3
make breathing breathing room for the
King now there's no route to d1 mate and
now next move you can go check here
bring the knight f6 and continue your
winning endgame however b3 was played
right away and exchanging the rook
really just helps Navarre I mean having
two two two two very nice pigs on the
seventh that's that's that's nothing not
something you want to throw away
with it does it for some reason we rook
captures nb7 rook captures and now a5
and now we have this position where it's
still white is better vada teas up a
pawn but it's a double G pawn and it's
hard to say how he will he will claim
his advantage and it's always a very
unpleasant
you were better you sacrificed for the
attack you were winning you know you
were winning then you you're not winning
you're still better but you still want
to prove that you are completely winning
so that's that's the worst place you
want to be well as a mindset when you're
playing the chess game so f3 we have
worked the c6 now with ideas of maybe
maybe going to prove the c2 going for
some GG to pawn ideas so look back to d2
not allowing this King to f7 Navarre
starts improving the position of the
king came to be too and now King e6 we
have Knight to c3 and now rook to d6
offering a rook trade but rookie do
check King to f5 although capturing was
also possible and then starting in the
march with the king he is sorry if you
could rigidly reach the be 5 square it
should be very good for you but ok
rookie do check King f5 and the now
tonight's to e4 attacking the rook rook
to d1 and knight back to c3 pushing the
room back rook to d3 again repeating
Knights to be one and now Knight to d5
and oK we've King to see two attacking
the rook knight back to be four with
check King to be 2 we have knight back
to d5 by navara saying that I'm very
satisfied with a draw here but evaded to
decline night
a3 he wants to go to c4 and go after the
beep on Knights the e3 and now comes
Knight to c4 as planned offering a night
raid as the beep on his under attack
Knight captures on c4 with check be
captures and now a four by navara now
Navarro has a passed pawn weave King to
see two attacking the rook but rook the
b3 we have rook to t2 and now rook the B
for attacking the c4 pawn we have King
to c3 and now pushing the King back rook
to b3 check King to see the route before
again navara offers the draw
came to c3 rook the b3 check kink to d4
now with it again declines the draw and
now III noir starts pushing his past
pawn rook the a2 blocking and now kink
the e6 not allowing the king some very
important square squares here if King d5
King here and if you capture the pawn
somehow could be it could be dangerous
so c5 but now this is this is really
pushing it yes you do get a passport but
so does so does Navarro Navarro now has
two passports and that's not gonna be
pleasant with g4 with it creates another
passport H captures F characters and b4
now we have g5 and now comes look the b2
now of course you cannot afford the
trade route k1 but now a - now b3 and
rook the b1 is the threat how are you
how are you ever going to stop this yeah
we have g6 but now b3 that we have c6
that if g7 it's still not a problem just
King to f7 blocking and if c6 Roxy - now
the recover is the C file the King
covers g8 White has no way of queening
the pawns
so c6 right away but now rook to c2 we
have looked the f1 cutting the King off
from the from the defense of the pawn
after it's pushed but now b2 we have g7
and now of course rook captures and g2
we have c7 and now King to d7 and with
now the rock covering this square the
King covering this square B 1 and a 1
are both winning it was in this position
almost 64 that with it resigned the game
and finally a well-deserved victory for
Davi Navarro who really you know
completed a Herculean task by by
stopping the attack and then by winning
this endgame but like I said it's it's
the worst kind of mindset to have when
when you're kind of when you're better
than you're winning then you're no
longer winning but you're still better
you can still just continue playing
chess but you want to force a win
because you were better at some point in
the game and then this happens it's a
really tough break for vidit who really
wanted this win to take the tournament
to one whole round before it ends but
still we do have the standings here and
we just we sorry unfortunately we do
have to take away the
the the morphe had away from vidit as
the the attack was not successful but
yeah here are the standings with it
still in the lead because he was a one
and a half point in the lead followed by
Nikita be to go Vanessa Fallujah and
Anton David Anton bahara with four and a
half young she still do the same
Shanklin and David navara now with four
and a four out of eight Marcus trogir
pencil heart accretion with three and a
half and Mills command alias still in
last place with which two and a half out
of eight so out really really an
impressive game I do hope you enjoyed it
really a brutal attacking it and that
yeah I do say okay it's a disgusting
engine line that Quinta a4 idea that we
discussed but you know if if rashidun is
Medina I've had this position maybe or
maybe mijo tiled you know who knows what
would happen here or it maybe even Paul
Morphy himself in positions like these
you know true attackers you know did did
wonders but yeah I do hope you enjoyed
it I would like to thank Arkady schnitz
which she pink will lock at a rock
additionally and Tammy Orion for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thankful for watching and I will see you
soon
continuing the coverage of the proctors
festival we were going into the final
round
continue the Paul Morphy saga and of
course checking up on your wonderful
suggestions so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day